guys earlier this month valve released
what is being called by some people the
biggest patch in csgo history now there
were a few weeks in and one LAN event
I'm here to tell you that it [ __ ]
sucks so here we are a few days after
blast pro series Sao Paulo
the first LAN event following Valve's
big change to the csgo economy now in
case you've been living under a rock or
just playing apex legends or something
here's the TLDR
valve at least a giant patch it changed
the OGG the m4a1 ask a couple things in
some maps but the big thing you need to
know is that the round lost bonus system
kind of the backbone of the csgo economy
was fundamentally changed as you guys
know in csgo if you lose a round you get
some bonus cash to help you catch up now
that hasn't changed what has changed is
that in the past if you lost for for
example and won around then lost the
following round you'd be reset
economically meaning your round loss
bonus would reset to a big fat goose egg
as no longer the case what happens now
is do you lose four in a row you win one
you lose the next one you go down one
rung on the round loss bonus ladder not
back down to zero so you still have cash
now the round loss bonus system has more
or less been set in stone since time
immemorial
as far as csgo is concerned the patch in
October of last year notwithstanding so
you can understand why a lot of the
community we're losing their collective
heads over this patch everybody and
their mother released a YouTube video I
wrote a big diatribe on reddit about how
it's either the best thing ever or the
worst thing ever for csgo really quickly
it went like this if you thought it was
bad it was because it was a broken ass
comeback mechanic it punished teams
apparently for winning and it was too
easy on teams who were throwing now if
you're one of the ones who like the
patch it went like this it doesn't
matter that the comeback mechanics are
so much stronger because it just means
there'll be more gun rounds in an
average csgo map and the better team
will always win more gun rounds so
although the score
we'll be closer the game's outcome won't
actually change now that's all fine and
good in theory but we need to see how it
plays out in practice now of course we
had a few weeks of online action
including ECS and one game in particular
where this new round lost bonus system
had an effect on to use money has been
getting rekt even they've been running
sunny rounds in a road they've been
losing lots of players not have been
doing a lot so the economic damage and
they've North won one round and already
vitality can't really put together a
full life shoutouts to North for
qualifying for UCS finals but let's be
honest here the real test is land over
the weekend we had our first since the
csgo patch that is blast pro series sal
paulo so how did it turn out well
pretty much according to [ __ ] this
tournament happened like it was written
down in a script the good teams won
their games the not-so-good teams lost
their games and not every score line was
1614 you would presume that Valve made
this round loss bonus change so that
games could get closer together more
tight score lines more gun rounds more
action although I don't really know why
that's necessary but it actually didn't
turn out to be the case I've got a
completely entirely unscientific
comparison for you
I took blast Pro Series saw Paulo and
compared it to the last blast Pro Series
event which was Lisbon now there are
almost the same teams in attendance
it was the same format but it was not
obviously on the new patch
I took the average round differential of
each tournament and compared them and
you know what blast pro series Lisbon
actually had closer games and closer
score lines on average than blast Pro
Series now Paulo so I'm left asking what
was the [ __ ] point of this patch if
games didn't get markedly closer and
nothing really changed astrologist still
the best liquid is still the second-best
by a really wide margin and phase clan
still can't do anything bless their
souls before this I feel like CS goes
meta was delicate valve would tweak
and like a very still pond that small
droplet would make big ripples lately
valve has been dropping some big rocks
into that very still pond was there a
problem with csgo before was it broken
was it boring here's a conspiracy theory
for you this change comes about a year
at the very least ten months after a
certain danish team had been dominating
the competitive scene with very lopsided
scores in both grand finals of two
majors even if this patch pans out the
way valve wants it to and games get
closer score lines get tighter it won't
matter for the best team in the world
because they're the best at managing
their economy do the best at managing
your economy and they're the best
[ __ ] team at gun rounds so what's the
point on top of all of the things that
are wrong with this patch already even
if that conspiracy theory is true they
[ __ ] that up too
so while this economic change may be
giving you a few more gray hairs in your
matchmaking games so far in pro play it
hasn't been the most impactful change
hasn't even come close to having the
impact that a lot of youtubers pundits
and the rest of us thought it might but
there's one thing I know almost for sure
the next biggest change in csgo history
is probably just around the corner
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
you